so you're basically saying i i am
against reality
that's that's what you're saying
so the question is now okay
how do i do this how do i become
formless myself
well some of the things that we've said
are well you got to have a pair of balls
you got to be brave because it's it it
is
it is initially
frightening
to lose
that
artificiality
and
our will to control the world so that
our artificiality we believe will
function
you see you don't you don't dare let
your uke come in and do whatever
right that's where you start for but why
don't you let them do whatever if
they're doing whatever that's whatever
is still something and so you still have
something to blend with
you don't need them to do this thing
you see
they're they're doing what they're doing
the problem was you can't go with it
so that's that's
that's frightening you're too nervous
you're too unwilling to let go and
that's why i always talk about the fear
the fear your the fear is in you you
won't risk this and and all i can do is
put before you i'm not dead
i didn't die from risking it
my world did not fall out from under me
in fact my technique worked better my
world is fuller
my life is richer
what what's really holding us back
i i have
you know that i think that's still a
legitimate question even if you want to
follow follow the buddhist paradigm of
well don't ask how the arrow got there
just pull it out okay that that has
logic but it's still very interesting to
ask
and i don't i don't mind the
the fact that the judeo-christian you
know this is why
you do that
okay this is why
and you might be i
think incorrectly going well because
adam and eve eat the fruit
you know
i don't think that's but i think in that
narrative
there's archetypal archetypal
elements that explain why
psychologically we just
we can't do it
right we we are in the garden
everything's fine
and the animals and man are living
together i mean think about it right
there's no division
because how do i know that i'm a man and
not an animal because the animals don't
live where i live and i don't live where
the animals live and i wear clothes and
animals don't wear clothes
you see but in the in the garden
who's what
there's a hierarchy but it's not a
separation
and when do you get effed up
when you start thinking with forms
knowledge
the tree of knowledge
the tree of good and evil right and
wrong
right up and down left and right now the
world starts getting divided and when
the world gets divided [\h__\h] you're out
you're out
i don't see
how that narrative could be understood
any other way unless you're an idiot and
you actually believe that you know
we're the product of several ancestral
relationships
right
very naive i think i think it's trying
to tell us
the same thing
this is this is how you got f'd up you
are you are stuck
in in by this dual dualistic thinking
this separation this
you know what are called dichotomies
this binary dichotomy is going on
if you if you read it well what happened
what happened
well she kind of was
just
a mixture of desire and
and and kind of like envy like why do
you get to make the rules
and uh you know kind of like
well why not even
you know
uh
and then what sets in
fear see the narrative tells you fear
sets in right because god's walking
through
the forest
right and he must have done it before
but now they're afraid
i mean it's all right there that's what
we do
right we go we go well i i i have this
desire i covet this thing i want my kid
to come in like this so i can do this
damn technique
right you pick something already in the
desire you have a discriminating mind
and a discriminating mind needs binary
opposition
not this that
not that this
and now you have knowledge good and evil
right or wrong
right and with that you have fear
because i have a preference and i don't
want the other one to come in
and now god walks on by and scares the
[\h__\h] out of you
because you you can't get rid of those
fictions you can't get rid of those
constructs
i mean i understand the parable it's not
maybe it's not god maybe it's your
master who's in formless and he's asking
you to be
just [\h__\h] foreign a break
i mean it's perfect if you had to ride
it wouldn't you
wouldn't that be the way to ride it okay
there's this ultimate garden and every
there's no real division
perfect story
but it's happening here on the map your
everything is already right there for
you but you won't you don't want it you
want something else
and that's where the problem starts
okay so i recommend
that what you try and do
is
kind of make a singular effort
it doesn't always work
do you try it
do something to get rid of that initial
aggressive intention that's coming in
from your uke because that is where your
all this starts when they start coming
in at you you start the the preferencing
and the fear and now you're picking and
then it doesn't fit and now you're
wrapped up okay so
if i'm getting nervous
or starting that cycle at the moment
that my uke comes in
don't do your technique there
can con and let the body mind relax
okay because you already responded to
that thing
and in that relaxed state you might have
a better chance of allowing what's
happening the other tool that i want to
give you is the age-old one is that
there's no technique for this
okay it's about immersion and explosion
so
go back to the basics you need to be by
someone who's formless
and you need to
get [\h__\h] by them because you're gonna
get kicked you're gonna get a chomp in
the throat you know what i'm saying and
you kind of like okay i get how this is
i get what's going on okay
in in that same way you're also
developing your body for
functioning without necessarily you
thinking
you see
and that's about familiarity because if
you're exposing yourself you're doing
more reps right
okay and so when you're when your body
can kind of take over
and you've got to a certain point you
might find it easier now to let your
mind not start that cycle
okay i'm not saying that because your
body is now having muscle memory
you you get to you know
uh
you now have an unfettered mind that
doesn't that's not it but what happens
is is that you're so exposed to that
initial
thing that jacks you up
that your body starts
feeling and sensing the
how futile it is to keep getting anxious
at that state
right on maybe on the 5th or 100th rep
of someone coming in
but after 10 000
your body's gonna go really
really this is i seem to have survived
10 000 of these things i don't need to
hold my breath anymore okay and the body
starts to release
and when the body releases them you
might have a chance for the mind again
for some people will other people know
so
it goes back to how often are you around
your teacher how often are you on the
mat okay but not for the obvious reasons
let me practice more forms
okay
any other comments or questions yes
during the
watch part halloween party yeah you
mentioned about you get tired it's
because you're anxious
so i was kind of focusing on that
the first half i was totally anxious
because i'm like i don't know as many
moves as everybody does here on this
obviously yeah so i was worried about it
so i know you want to make a point let's
let's pull out more so you see
how many moves you you got partitions
now
right
you understand
i want you to keep saying what you're
saying i don't want you to change but i
want to point out to everyone in our
normal understanding that i have the
tree
of knowledge you see i have the
divisions okay which was my mistake well
i pooped out and i rested and i said
okay i'm not gonna worry about it i'm
just gonna look stupid if i have to i'm
gonna try to hey let's stop there so
often the pride right i i have a
preference because i don't want
my pride to be wounded but if i let go
of my pride go on
so the second half i went in i'm still i
just didn't need a target
i went through the reps
and i just did not get as tired and that
worrying about being able to do me was
tiring me yeah just like you said yes
and so i kind of experimented with that
and i feel like that was the only thing
i really got from this session that's a
huge thing but huge okay and now the
thing is to be able to do it
when they're really trying to kill me
and i only have one rep to get it right
okay at full speed that's the idea which
we're nowhere near right in this class
all right and something else
about
five or seven years ago
uh we were asking the same question
before all these people showed up yeah
it's the same dialogue same thing
and the answer is
just to calm down and don't pick a
technique yeah or if you only have one
technique do one technique but just let
yourself get stuck and keep going and
find something yeah i noticed a lot of
people get really fettered and really
tense
try to pick a technique and it wouldn't
work and then stop yeah i'll keep coming
slowly to calm you down to find another
technique yeah i want you to do the same
if i if i miss it just keep attacking me
i'll find another technique or something
else to do so back to my point about
don't lose that intention right don't
stop okay just keep coming i had you
re-grab on me right no just keep that
initial attention we're still training
you're still giving an action i'm still
responding and blending okay
that's what calmed me down
or calms me down yeah
so i can try to just relax and blend
whatever i've been given
exactly exactly
um
this thing of the techniques right
those pie pieces those partitions
that the fictions
okay
be honest
how many of you tried different
techniques for the sake of doing
something different okay that's what
rob's talking about
you you
if what you were doing before was in
perfect harmony with the attack that's
coming in that is a spontaneous
expression
okay
now when you try to do something
different you're you're not spontaneous
anymore you have the same partitioning
same tree of knowledge going
right
so don't
don't judge your techniques
don't i get a lot of you will say sorry
to me and i'm always like what
what possibly could you do wrong
in this thing right if when i mentioned
don't re-grab it's because you're going
to get hit and i'm pretty sure you don't
want to get hit
right but it's not wrong
not for me i'm going to hit you
right
you get what i'm saying or sometimes you
did something weird and you're all sorry
i'm like what this is no place to
be like that and a thing that is very
interesting about the garden of eden
narrative
is that there were two trees but a lot
of people don't know there were two
trees and the other tree is the tree of
life okay and that that's the one where
it had no rules on
you were supposed to go to that one and
you were supposed to be and the tree of
life is about formlessness
okay
isn't that imaginative
it's so weird because we acknowledge
[\h__\h] that's good
right let me have that apple and ready
wait the other one's called tree to life
you know i was watching north macdonald
on the answer nine on if you guys
haven't seen the stand-ups awesome
you know i made it my new year's
resolution is to not die this year he's
all cause
you know that's got to be the suckiest
thing ever
and i think that the doctors the medical
profession they're getting distracted by
disease because they're like look i can
cure your arthritis yeah but uh am i
still gonna die yes
i should work on this death thing okay
so it's kind of like that
right when you see the perspective i was
like why do i want that knowledge i want
life
okay that's what i wanted to like
which is the tree we have
in the back back there is the tree of
life virginia brought that tree from
where
uh a church museum store so there's some
traditions where they're very keen on
this tree of life